and what's happening so
far is that i'm spending way too much
time
and um but i'm sort of dragging him down
to my level
and that he will spend a lot of time as
well and that then he will
um he will get in time trouble and we
will both be in time trouble
and uh so far i've handled that a bit
better
okay let's go for d4
let's see what he has in store
he played the king's camp story the
queen's gambit against me and um
in the recently saint louis event
here goes for the semitarish
okay i guess i'll take and he goes for
the
boring line
oh well okay
this isn't much
this is much at all
okay you go v4 i suppose
it takes he clearly knows this stuff
which it's not it's not really a part of
my plan
okay so his idea is i think to go
measure d7
then then knight c6
or maybe just to go bishop f6 next
would be nice to know
queen b6 and then rook d8
yeah it makes a lot of sense
probably don't have anything
name don't think so
i guess i'll just castle the rook d8
i'll go
where will i go
yeah i mean my first intention was just
go queen b3
but now i was thinking of some
tricks with rooks c1
like hoping for knight c6 and then i
take psych the queen
and if bishop f6 i may have queen a4
there should be a that's nothing okay
we'll just we'll just exchange the
queens
hope for the best
okay nowadays six is a bit surprising
i guess still a very decent look
so his idea here is to go knight c5
threatening both e4
and and knight a4
okay so i'll start with no f3 is no good
obviously
can i do that
okay didn't see what to do so i'd just
take the idea was to be a6 i go knight
c6 and i'm very slightly better and
some of its opposite color bishops
position
but now i think um
i'm not at all better it's um
slight weakness on base
b7 b6 is completely
outweighed by the fact that he has the
bishop here
maybe there was even some
um night fishbefore funny business that
could happen there
so now i'm just trying to play it safe
before not before next maybe
okay we're bringing rainbow
king along
yeah i think
getting a bit shorter in time again
and blundering upon
that is pretty badass
okay yeah i'm gonna
i'm gonna need a miracle to save this
one now
night c4 just pick playing too slowly
and poorly
and might be finally
getting getting the just
sort of punishment for it
let's try to try to keep the game going
it's playing very fast
okay
i i mean i don't think this is any good
i'm just
trying to use
any
any sort of excuse to try and set up a
fortress
i think it's not even going to be close
enough
but it's got him thinking of it finally
okay now i have to go to v3 in order to
free the knight
um probably might as well give up
e3 oh [ __ ] that
pawn really matters too much
okay so the idea is to go f4
and then then i'll go with the king
to d4 to d4 and claim that i have some
some sort of fortress okay now
go knight
to e4 i think 56
just hoping that this kind of works
good thing is i think you probably
missed it
if you hadn't got kmgi uh g4 i probably
would have gone to h4
trying to close up the king side and i'm
gonna have some store fortress
so it goes for f6
i'll have to take but i think i will
okay getting dangerously short time
i do have some drawing chances too i
think
okay another fate win upon
that's got to be a good start
probably will go e5
this is getting a bit iffy for him
okay i'll actually take it it looks a
bit counter intuitive to give it a
passport like this but
you just have to go g4 otherwise his
pawn was queening
i might be doing okay actually e7 seems
like a
safe primo i don't think he's winning g4
and because of that i believe i'm sort
of escaping
okay now i've got knight g6 this little
trick getting the knight t5
can i take on g4 and thus i believe the
game should be drawn
king of three i think he has no way no
way to make progress
b6 i just gave a check
okay